Welcome to our week six.
It's time to negotiate the next
generation social contract.
So I'm looking forward to a
really exciting and fruitful
week.
All the instructions are now
on the platform on week six,
so all you need to
do is to go to it.
You'll see instructions
for how to find your team,
your role assignments.
Then you go through, and
you'll complete the preparation
survey, you'll negotiate
online with your counterparts,
hopefully in the same time
zone where you are located.
And then as you complete
the survey form at the end,
to record your
settlements, those of you
who are taking the course for
certification and for a grade
will get some extra credit
as described on the platform.
So we're excited about it.
We're looking forward to
hearing what you have in mind
for shaping the future of work.
As a bonus, we will
provide a facilitator.
One of our MBA students, what
we call our community TAs,
will be assigned to your group.
What is a facilitator?
A facilitator is just what
that term sounds like.
It's a neutral
person, it's a person
who helps move you
through the process
without influencing
your proposals
or the particular terms of
the agreement that you reach.
So this individual will
help you in scheduling times
or answering questions
and be a liaison back
to the rest of us as needed.
So use the facilitator
at your choice,
and we'll see how
all of this works.
The deadline is Thursday at the
end of the day UTC time 11:59
PM.
So it's important that
you and your teammates
work on an agreement
on when to negotiate,
engage in the course
discussion as instructed.
And we'll see what we
learn from this experience.
Next week is the grand
finale of this course,
and we have a special event.
It's called a live video
event or video chat,
whatever one wants to call it.
On Tuesday, May 10th
at UTC time 8:00 PM,
we will have an hour and
a half live interaction
with all of you, where
we will summarize
what we have taken away as the
key lessons from this course.
And we'll incorporate
the materials
not only from the
course but also
your materials from the
polls that you completed,
the surveys, the assignments
that you did, the discussions
that you've had on the forum,
all of this will come together.
And with your
engagement, directly
by passing on questions
to us or comments
as we go along, for
an hour and a half
we will see what did we learn
from this, where are we going,
and how can we use
all of this material
effectively, not
only for yourselves,
but for external audiences who
are also interested in shaping
the future of work.
So please put this
on your calendar,
be ready with
questions or comments.
We'll send you
information next Monday,
the day before
this event, on how
to tune in, where to link
in for this interesting,
I hope interesting,
and informative wrap-up
for the course.
Let me make a special
request of you
to make sure that we bring
your voices into this process,
one segment of the summary
will ask the question
"What is our key message
to the future leaders who
will shape the future of work?"
Business leaders and
HR professionals,
labor leaders and
their advocates,
government policymakers,
and those of us
in the education field.
So make sure that, on the
discussion board this week,
where we will post
questions or a place
where you can add your thoughts
to each of these stakeholders,
that you bring your
voice into this process.
And we'll incorporate that
into the discussion next week,
Tuesday.
So I look forward to seeing
what you have on your mind
and what message
you want to deliver
to these groups who will help
to shape the future of work.
Last week we had a very, very
rich, and engaging discussion,
and, in fact, throughout
this course, many of you
commented on the
subject for last week
and that is: "What's
the future of Labor?"
Is there still a need
for labor organizations,
for unions as we've called
them over many years,
and in fact over
several centuries?
Is there a new form
of representation?
Are there new ways in which
workers can get a voice at work
and assert their interests
and work with their employers
to shape the future of work?
Most of you do see
the need for some form
of labor representation,
maybe not for everyone,
but for the people
who really want
to have a collective
voice at the workplace.
But you also see the need for
change, and for innovation,
to build on the
strengths of what
unions have done
historically for so
many workers around the world.
You talked about
the need to expand
more labor-management
partnerships,
like the one out at Kaiser
Permanente that we discussed.
Many of you focused, in
a very rich dialogue,
over the need for what
you call digital unions.
That is using information
technology, social media,
and related mechanisms
to convey your ideas
and to communicate with
each other across the world.
And indeed you talked about
the need for global unions,
because obviously today,
where people work, how people
are affected by jobs
that are created
by companies around the world,
is not simply a national issue.
Some of you talked
about the need
to return to these interesting
organizations called guilds,
where workers came
together cooperatively
to enhance their profession
or their particular occupation
and to work to enhance
their professionalism.
You talked about
the need for apps
to share information
on where good jobs are
and good employers
are, along the lines
that we used in the good
jobs survey that some of you
have done.
And then many of you
talked about the need
for new forms of advocates
for low-wage workers
in the United States, in
Europe, in developing countries
all around the
world, particularly
focusing on the role that
NGOs are now playing.
So I think the bottom
line of all of this:
don't just observe these trends.
Get involved,
whether it's working
on the side of
advocates for labor,
whether it's enriching
and strengthening
the role that HR plays
in our organizations,
whether it's thinking
about the future of labor
policy in our countries,
or whether you're
like me working in
the education sphere,
either on the university
level with the outside world,
all of you in this
global-based online course,
or are school students in high
schools and community colleges.
We all have a role to play.
We've emphasized that
throughout this course, now
it's time for us to
put our ideas to work.
So I look forward to a
very invigorating week
of negotiations.
We'll summarize the
settlements that
are achieved next week
when we come together,
and we'll see if we can't
really summarize and bring
together what did
we learn, what are
the key takeaways
from our efforts
to shape the future of work.